مص روح حاضره في مونديال قطر ليس بمحمد
صلاح والمنتخب المصري بطبيعه الحال بل
بحسن شاكوش مؤدي المهرجانات الشعبيه
الشهير الذي كشف مؤخرا عن مشاركته في
الفعاليات الفنيه بالعرس الرياضي العالمي
الذي سيبدا بعد ايام النجم المصري والشعبي
فرح بالمشاركه ولا يابا بالاصوات المعارضه
له او لنوع اغنياته التي ربما يجدها البعض
غير مناسبه لتمثيل مصر لكنه ربما يستقوي
بالفيفا الذي اعلن عن كوني ما يقدمه شاكوش
يمثل جزءا كبيرا من الحياه في العالم
العربي جمعا كبير من المصريين على عدم
حضور المنتخب المصري في كاس العالم ولكن
بعضهم يفرح بحضوري فن جديد اصبح كما يرون
جزء من الهويه التعريفيه بهم خارجه بلادهم
ويرون ايضا انه لا يمكن او انكار ان
المهرجانات رغم كل الانتقادات لمواجهه
اليها صارت اداه للتعبير المصريه البصره
على راي المثل لولا اختلاف الاضواء لبارت
السلعه ولعل الاختلاف في الذوق العام يجعل
من المهرجانات التي يبغضها البعض الاخر
فلن حاضرا في اكبر تجمع رياضي عالمي سيرقص
عليها الكثيرون وربما سيتعرفون على شاكوش
وما يؤديه للمره الاولى لصباح العربيه ندى
حجازي القاهره